Okay, we're back.
Um
All right. Yeah, I don't know. My audio
drivers randomly crashed, I guess.
That's weird. Yeah, so Spencer um 4.0
4.0's good.
Uh
I'm editing Python puffer around now.
I'm doing like fixes so we can test
neural MMO via torch
and test the backend implementation
independently.
Uh
so there'll be some changes in the
Python. There might be a couple of
backend changes, but
4.0's pretty stable.
Yeah, I That's what's weird. It just
like broke my drivers and then OBS would
not recognize them after a uh driver
reboot
without me reopening it.
Annoying.
It's what it is.
I mean, puffer's going nicely.
Um we've got to fix the Python backend
so we can test some stuff. We got like
one major thing to figure out before 4.0
and we're good.
I can just get it to do a standalone for
this. This is super easy.
What model am I using? This is just
plaid whatever [ __ ] No, actually this
is on it.
Um
Uh the models are all dumb anyways.
Actually, I was almost almost on board
with this era brush one, but the token
limits are very low and um
it just like spams a ton for every query
and just eats budget quickly.
And it's also just like
not a good enough model either that it
can compensate.
Which is weird cuz I thought it was
decent on the benchmarks, but yeah.
Quick summary of what you're trying to
do.
So I work on puffer lib.
Uh you can see the project at puffer.ai.
Puffer lib is the highest performance
reinforcement learning library out
there.
We can train tiny models on specific
tasks at well over 10 million steps per
second.
We have a ton of example environments
here, everything from games to drone
driving and more.
Um I do all the development of this open
source. I run the project and I stream
all the dev on it.
Currently, I am working on the new raw
CUDA backend for puffer 4, which is
super super fast.
And uh we're having a problem where
one of our environments we cannot train
well and it's a very important
environment. So I'm currently figuring
out
um some like fallbacks that I can use to
test it and to isolate why stuff is not
working correctly.
I like how it just tries to break my
algorithm as like part of a minor
refactor.
Tell me again how good these models are
and how smart they are.
Yeah, no, but we're This is not like um
we're not doing like a oh, let the AI
edit the code base and screw up all of
our stuff without like doing anything
with it. This is not like my project.
This is serious difficult engineering
thing. I'm exhausted today, so I'm
letting it do some very very easy tasks
and like making sure it's not making a
mess of things.
Um
it doesn't matter what you use though,
what model you use. Like they just make
a mess of the code if you let them do
their thing.
Even for relatively simple stuff.
>> Offer breakout.
>> Yeah. It popping breakout that's just
the simplest end that seems to be
relatively consistent predictor of
whether your thing works.
It's actually too simple in some sense
cuz you can solve breakout with
some pretty bad algorithms.
Um so it's not always perfect, but
that's what we have grading 2048 for and
then ultimately neural MMO3.
Those are all nice.
Wait, rewards that should always be
zero.
Instead of copying uninitialized
the CPU rewards and terminals buffers
are not copied.
I'd be kind of surprised. I guess that
could be it.
Uh
Oh.
Wait, what?
Why is it like this, man?
It never sweeps.
Yeah.
I don't know how Alec does that. Not
sleeping is just like brutal.
No, actions are already in here
correctly, aren't they?
So then why?
It showed in 32 somewhere, didn't it?
Cuz what did we get? We get action D
type is in 32.
>> Liam Stroll
Ooh.
If it's any good, that'd be nice.
That'd be super nice.
It's actually kind of funny. I know one
of the very good programmers I know went
and joined um
So, actually some of like the really
really good engineers that um
I knew from a couple of years ago were
like, "Man, if I could just get them to
build some stuff, environments would be
so much faster and stuff." I can kind of
just do all that stuff myself now.
It's almost always the end distributor
thing, isn't it?
ML degree in 2026
instead of doing what?
You could go get your degree in
underwater basket weaving instead.
Yeah, it's true. AI cannot cannot
properly weave baskets underwater.
They can weave them above water. So, you
know, I don't know about that one.
But
>> [snorts]
>> We have the under to the above water
basket weaving bot, but the underwater
one still is not cracked yet.
Yeah, that's a synchronizing copy. That
should be fine.
Hey, Lance.
We're trying to figure out why Neural
MMO is not training like it did before.
Kind of just the last thing for the
release is
the nice Neural MMO baseline and then we
can just run all our sweeps, clean stuff
up, and we're done.
So, I'm trying to get that stable today,
and I'm fixing up the Python back end so
we can run some back and forth tests.
one billion Neural MMO experiments
You mean one trill?
Probably one trill.
Yeah.
I think that'd be a fun thing to do.
It's only about 3 days of training run
on a tiny box.
The expected time
with buffer four.
Issues merging 4.0 into mine?
I just pushed a couple days ago all the
new Rakuten stuff
for four.
It does learn. We have um
grid, we've got 2048, we've got like
lots of different things.
Uh the Python version of it though,
that's what I'm messing with now.
Yeah, like 4.0 is um
it's experimental.
Now, our clients can get early um
like early ports for their stuff
assisted with if they want, but for the
most part
you probably just want to be on the
current public thing and then be
planning for the uh
the new thing.
Takes time.
4.0 is a lot of work.
This is just This is like different
thing I'm doing with the Python back end
now.
Most of the arms to already be in the
GPU.
I don't know how you would do that.
We do have nice buffering go for the GPU
transfers now.
8 to 9 mil yeah, you can get 8 to 9 mil.
Really small nets with efficient M's are
pushing 20 mil plus now single GPU.
>> [snorts]
>> And buffers is very very fast.
Ah, okay. So we've gotten into the
advantages.
Data set up serve GPU.
Personal information.
Why are you working with Sonnet?
Um well, it was because Opus was
spinning for too long, but now this is
spinning for too long. Actually, the
thing that I found the other day that
I'm almost happy with. They just need
like
better limits and a slightly better
model to serve.
Uh you can use Cerebras with open code.
And that serves like one or 2,000 tokens
per second.
Which means like it doesn't just feel
completely ass to be doing your work and
mostly be waiting for stupid language
model to give you a wrong answer.
Um you stay much more engaged, you stay
much more in control of everything. I
like it a lot. My best model they have
is just not great yet and uh the token
limits are really low.
One mil context update. Yeah, it's
called that.
No, I'd really just like to find um
I want to play around more with with
open code and stuff. I'm sick of giving
Anthropic money. These models serve way
too slow.
Like I'm only doing this today cuz I'm
exhausted from um
like maxing out bench.
Cuz otherwise this is just a completely
stupid way to do work.
Okay, this is supposed to have a stream
attached to it potentially.
Are not worth using?
You two think.
What's the um
the ZAI or whatever model they have?
I actually was getting some stuff out of
it for like very simple little changes.
Oops.
Oh, because they paid for the ads. [ __ ]
you, Anthropic.
I'd be way happier giving these guys
money if I could cuz this is like an
actually cool company that does
awesome stuff.
Here.
Yeah, this one.
Yeah, they need to be serving more
stuff. I think honestly they're doing so
much business that they don't even care
about this inference API and they're
mostly doing bigger deals. Cuz like
their stuff is actually really freaking
cool.
It's smart, but not
Well, Cerebras doesn't make the models,
right? They just serve them.
So I mean really all they need to do is
they just need to serve something
decent.
The funny thing is you don't want a
PyTorch model.
Like if you're writing your [ __ ] in
PyTorch, you're probably not thinking
about um
I mean without heavy custom kernels at
least. Like you're probably not thinking
about your architecture uh performance
to the point that you should be thinking
about doing chips for it.
They got 300 mil funding. Oh my gosh,
guy that does not that does not tell you
anything.
People are getting billions in funding
these days while not doing anything.
Chat Jimmy is their tech demo.
What are they serving at 16k a second?
What are they doing besides serving
models? Yes, it's it's a hardware
company, right? Cerebras, they have
like iPad size chips.
And uh you can run a lot of stuff on
them.
Oh, 8 bill.
What Cerebras serve um
I think it is faster, but I don't think
it's that much.
Okay, well they're serving um
120 bill at 3k tokens.
So I don't know if they have it
optimized that much for the like really
much smaller language models.
Oh, wait, they do have llama 3.1. Yeah,
so this is just not optimized then cuz
look, they're serving a 3.1 uh they're
serving 8 bill at 2.2K and they're
serving 120 bill at 3K. So, they just
didn't bother to optimize this one
because nobody uses this [ __ ]
Unless this is like a big mixture of
experts or something. I don't know what
the architecture is for this.
A6 is only like a 6 bill.
Wait, what?
It's fast though.
Now, the question is if they serve
larger models at reasonable speeds.
What am I working on? I'm trying to
figure out um I'm fixing our Python back
end so I can debug neural MMO.
Let me make sure it didn't break
anything.
You know what?
Does this train?
Oh, yeah, this does train. This is our
float 32 back end, isn't it?
Apparently, I fixed float 32 at some
point cuz that didn't used to work.
By making the software harder. I don't
know what they're like
The thing is I don't know it like with
Cerebras, you're using the entire wafer
for the chip.
Um
So, I don't know what they're doing. I
don't It's not just like a standard
chip, is it?
It'd be pretty cool that we get a
we get a little chip for like the popper
minigrower or whatever.
We just do like a 1024 minigrower or
whatever.
And then we give it like enough space.
Maybe you get like 4KB for ops.
That'd be cool.
I'll double check on one thing real
quick.
No, this will copy for us, right?
Then this will copy for us.
I hate torch. You know, actually, I have
to take a second to think like, oh,
there's a copy behind the scenes.
Two min_group layers.
Uh, we got our dense forms in here, and
those aren't supposed to be there.
They shouldn't break it completely,
though.
It was the architecture diff.
At least partially.
Uh, this is not perimeter map, 40K.
No.
Bias pools
decoder
Oh, this thing is not like returning
anything. This thing is just spinning.
Oh, it's the fraud.
Hang on.
>> I don't even have a yellow on my
computer anymore, do I?
Ah, yes, very useful. Spin for 5
minutes. Delete the breakpoint.
Sure, buddy.
Should have kept ratio equals one
throughout training.
Okay, well, that is that's now fixed.
So.
All right, cool.
I think we got it now, right?
>> It's like
a fifth of the speed of um
our other one, but
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right. Ours is so much
faster than this.
Reacts faster. Damn. All right.
But, we can commit this now.
Models Python buffer of line 15.
Yeah.
Very nice.
Oh, we probably don't have GDP working,
huh?
Well, I guess we have to check it,
right?
Let's see if this still works with torch
run.
All my docs.
How do I read my own docs for how to do
this?
Oh, look. I have the exact command on
the website.
Isn't that convenient?
I won't be able to do the ridiculous.
Even 4,000 is nothing.
Get all the damn data and train the
model already.
What is this thing doing?
I do remember this bug being like some
stupid screwy thing.
Frozen around Python.
This should just not be a thing. This is
really dumb.
I really want this thing to be running
so I can like
go get dinner and have it be done by the
time I get back.
And this so annoying, man.
And came out.
I hate it so [ __ ] much, man.
Language is just ass.
I don't even know why this is a
possibility.
At least I spend time debugging like
mostly sane things
in C and CUDA.
This is just so [ __ ] dumb.
It's literally that. I hate Python.
I hate Python, man.
Jesus, what a stupid What a completely
stupid
language
ecosystem, whatever.
All right.
I'm getting dinner then. I got to run.
We'll see if that's decent. I'll see if
maybe I work on purpose as well later.
I don't know. I might do a little stream
later.
I might not.
Regardless, thank you all for tuning in.
I'm traveling tomorrow. Should be back
Wednesday.
If you're interested in my stuff,
buffer.ai. Feed the buffer a star on
GitHub. It helps me out a ton. It's
free.
Uh just for you want to get involved.
And I still need to update this stupid
link. It's just J Suarez now on X.